we're not saying hasta la vista to
Schwarzenegger but it might be better
for everyone if he takes it easy in his
next role while Fubar doesn't feature
Arnold Schwarzenegger at his physical
peak it's still exciting to see the
action Superstar take on a brand new
role over five decades into his career
as much of an icon as Schwarzenegger is
it's clear that age has become an issue
for him the beginning of the first
episode sees Arnie's Luke Bruner leaping
into action on an infiltration Mission
using a fire truck has covered a sneak
past security the issue is that it's
glaringly apparent that Schwarzenegger
isn't really who we're looking at and
that it's someone else doing tuck and
roll stunts and jumping off of fire
engines it makes for a pretty poor first
impression raising questions about later
scenes where Arnold is or isn't called
into action from hopping between cars
and high-speed car chases to jumping out
of planes it's clear that some of the
biggest action scenes in Fubar don't
involve the series star for the most
part in pubar Schwarzenegger doesn't get
too involved in the fight scenes but
when he does it's usually a little more
Awkward than the creators may have
intended